bonsoir à tous
m'occupant de la direction créative de
sa marque un jour un client m'a demandé
de lui créer une montre iconique
je lui ai répondu que malheureusement
pas possible on crée pas des icônes par
contre
je lui ai proposé et de lui créer une
cohérence esthétique
dans son produit dans sa montre qu'il
voulait créer afin
qu'au fil du temps elle a une chance de
devenir au conique
donc c'est de ça que je vais vous parler
ce soir la cohérence esthétique
c'est la clé en fait pour les créatifs
la cohérence esthétique pour une marque
c'est la clé
mais la cohérence esthétique c'est quoi
je vais commencer par vous expliquer
vous montrer quelques exemples
alors un exemple que tout le monde
connaît le logo shell
donc chez la base c'était des
commerçants de kérosène évidemment mais
aussi des commerçants
de coquillages orientaux et d'antiquités
et ils ont choisi au départ
il coquille de moules en fait comme logo
qui symbolisait un petit peu tout ce
qu'il faisait
alors on voit c'est la première qui a
été fait en 1901 et qui était pas on va
dire
qui était assez difficile à retenir et
c'est quelques années plus tard qu'ils
ont décidé d'évoluer donc on garde le
même concept de base le coquillage qui
devient en fait un pétoncle une coquille
Saint-Jacques qui est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus graphique beaucoup plus
facile à retenir qui va évoluer au fil
du temps au départ en noir et blanc
jusqu'en 1948
où là la couleur arrive le rouge et le
jaune
avec le nom de la marque au milieu qui
va évoluer au fil du temps
jusqu'au 1971
ou Raymond la vie à designer très connu
de l'époque
à redessiner
le pictogramme de la pétoncle qui
devient le logo vraiment officiel qu'on
le trouve encore aujourd'hui
mais sans le nom de la marque donc en
1971 le logo donc est modifié avec le
nom de la marque en dessous et il va
disparaître en 1999 ou là finalement la
corporate
identity le pictogramme de la marque n'a
plus de nom
donc là on est dans un cas où au fil du
temps la marque n'a plus de besoin de
communiquer sur son nom on connaît son
pictogramme on connaît son logo Pascal à
base il y a une cohérence esthétique qui
a été créée
un autre exemple la bouteille de coca
que tout le monde connaît
donc à la base elle n'a pas été au
départ la même qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
donc en 1899 une bouteille a été créée
une bouteille assez standard mais déjà
avec un logo déjà très distinctif qui
est
donc en relief sur le verre et ensuite
elle évolue il y a une étiquette il y a
un logo elle va changer de couleur
et c'est en 1917 que la marque vraiment
décide
de créer quelque chose de différent
il voulait le brief était de
qu'on puisse reconnaître cette bouteille
dans le noir on la touchant et également
lorsqu'elle était cassée
que tu étais brisée au sol on devait
reconnaître que c'était une bouteille de
coca
et ensuite la forme s'inspire
d'une fève de de cacao et elle s'appelle
la bouteille contour on l'a on l'a
surnomme la bouteille contour qui va
évoluer au fil du temps
donc au fil du temps cette bouteille
elle est devenue iconique on la
reconnaît et ce qui a permis au fil du
temps aussi plus tard lorsqu'on a changé
les contenants lorsque la l'étiquette la
couleur est arrivée dans l'étiquette on
a utilisé d'autres matières l'aluminium
par exemple on pouvait faire quelque
chose de très différent vu que déjà
cette bouteille était connue du grand
public elle était devenue iconique
un autre exemple
au niveau peut-être plus conceptuel là
pour la marque Gucci le concept du
bambou
donc le bambou à la base il a été
utilisé ce concept pour faire une anse
de sac à main après la guerre en fait
donc la marque avec des problèmes
d'approvisionnement d'approvisionnement
de matière
et de cuire donc et ils ont décidé
d'utiliser le bambou comme anse c'était
plus simple à l'époque d'obtenir ce type
de matière
et ça donnerait quelque chose
d'intéressant et évidemment quelque
chose au fil du temps qui est devenu
iconique qui était très distinctif sur
le marché de l'époque et ensuite ce
concept aime vu tellement fort qu'on a
décidé de l'utiliser dans d'autres
typologies de produits bouteille de
parfum bijoux montres etc
donc vous voyez que la cohérence
esthétique elle peut avoir un effet sur
quelque chose qui évolue au fil du temps
au logo un produit mais aussi ça peut
être conceptuel c'est un concept qu'on
va décliner sur plusieurs typologies de
produits ou d'objets
un autre exemple qui m'est plus
personnel la marque Fortis
spécialisée dans les montres de pilote
d'aviation
m'a redemandé de d'évoluer une montre de
pilote iconique qui existait depuis très
longtemps utilisé par les pilotes mais
la marque avait aussi pour but de
changer de position on va dire il
voulait avoir plus de valeur changer la
position de reproduit faire un produit
un peu plus haut de gamme
et pour faire ça en fait j'ai dû
déconstruire un peu cette montre qui
était iconique bien analysée et surtout
m'immerger dans la marque et le monde
des pilotes en particulier les pilotes
j'y connais rien je connais pas du tout
ce monde
et c'est ça pour moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse dans mon métier dans la
création c'est de m'immerger dans des
mondes différents
c'est ça qui est passionnant la
curiosité
c'est la base de la création c'est la
base des créative je dis toujours un
créatif c'est pas quelqu'un avec un
grand col roulé noir qui fait des grands
dessins sur une feuille blanche
la plus grande qualité d'un créatif
c'est la curiosité et moi dans un
travail comme ça je m'immerge je me suis
immergé dans le monde des pilotes en y
concernant rien du tout
afin de lui amener quelque chose
d'intéressant donc je voulais amener de
la valeur à cette cette
montre en lui donnant une fonction pas
juste redessiner des choses juste plus
esthétiques donc pour moi la valeur
était d'amener des fonctions et j'ai
amené deux fonctions donc le GMT sur une
lunette tournante que tout le monde
connaît mais surtout une fonction qu'on
a décidé avec les pilotes qui a une
fonction toute simple en fait c'est la
mise à zéro entre -5 secondes et plus
secondes puis 5 secondes pardon qui
permet au pilote de se synchroniser lors
d'un départ d'un vol
et aussi j'ai retravaillé
quelques éléments un petit peu plus
lisibles et aussi de valeur de produits
qui sont des détails qui valorisaient
plus cette montre en fait mais la base
là ce qui m'a
l'immersion dans cette mare dans ce
monde des pilotes pour moi la valeur
ajoutée n'était pas de rajouter de la
matière précieuse c'était de rajouter
une fonction d'amener de la cohérence
mon but étant qu'un jour peut-être cette
marque sera enfin pardon ce produit par
cette marque cette ligne de produits
sera peut-être évoluée par un autre
designer donc il doit il doit
reconnaître les éléments pour pouvoir
évoluer au fil du temps
on a vu un petit peu ce que c'était la
cohérence esthétique mais est-ce qu'il y
a une méthode pour créer une cohérence
esthétique
il n'y a pas de méthode universelle en
fait il y a plusieurs méthodes ça dépend
la typologie de produits ou de la marque
ou pour qui on travaille il y a pas de
règles précises
donc ce que je vais essayer de vous
montrer aujourd'hui
c'est quelque piliers mais trois piliers
de travail qui me permet de chaque fois
d'inventer ou de créer des nouvelles
recettes dans chaque cas afin de créer
une cohérence esthétique pour une marque
donc ça se repose sur trois piliers le
pourquoi
la vision
et l'architecture ce que j'appelle
l'architecture esthétique d'un
pictogramme ou d'un produit
le pourquoi
c'est très important de savoir pourquoi
on fait quelque chose et ça évidemment
ça ne dépend pas que de moi ça dépend de
la management de la marque de la
stratégie mais c'est très important
aussi que le créatif participe à cette
décision
pourquoi on fait les choses
par et simple mais c'est très important
après la vision c'est le quoi qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire en fait
par quoi on va commencer
ou par quoi on va évoluer
et c'est la vision là c'est peut-être un
élément qui devient plus intéressant ou
la direction créative ou le designer le
créatif va avoir plus d'importance mais
c'est de là que tout part pas seulement
la direction créative mais également le
marketing l'ingénierie la vente tout
doit partir de la vision de la marque
ce qui est très dangereux
mais qui est intéressant aussi
mais une grave erreur souvent c'est de
partir d'une étude de marché
parce que l'étude de marché elle va
répondre
à un moment précis elle va répondre à un
besoin d'une clientèle à un moment
précis dans le temps mais c'est pas dit
que ce soit en cohérence avec la
stratégie de la marque et ça c'est très
dangereux
donc on repart toujours de la vision
globale et moi en tant que créatif pour
amener une cohérence esthétique et créer
des éléments qui constituent cette
cohérence esthétique si je n'ai pas une
stratégie claire et une vision claire de
la marque ça va être compliqué peut-être
que j'arriverai à lui faire quelque
chose qu'on aura du succès sur du court
terme mais sur du long terme c'est très
très dangereux
enfin l'architecture
lorsqu'on crée un logo lorsqu'on crée un
produit lorsqu'on crée une communication
pour une marque ce qui est important
c'est de créer des éléments qui vont
constituer
cette cohérence esthétique afin que des
équipes créatives différentes puissent
travailler avec une architecture avec
des outils
et finalement d'avoir une cohérence
globale esthétique dans toute la marque
qui part de logo à la communication et
aux produits
donc là je vous donne un exemple sur un
produit sur une montre
je crée quand même une sorte de boîte à
outils avec chaque élément
qui doit avoir une fonction qui doit
avoir une un lien avec un autre élément
le but étant de décomposer pour
recomposer comme je l'ai dit auparavant
au fil du temps peut-être un autre
designer un jour et spécialement aussi
le produit a du succès et qu'il devient
iconique au fil du temps s'il a la
chance de venir iconique bah notre
designers va pouvoir l'évoluer au fil du
temps donc c'est je compose une sorte de
d'architecture qui permet en décomposant
de au fil du temps qu'on puisse évoluer
chaque élément et on sait pourquoi il
est là et on sait dans quel sens et dans
quelle évolution
il se projette
là c'est un autre exemple je vais le
passer très rapidement
pour la marque est belle ou là on voit
bien que finalement entre la monteronde
et la montre carrée ce sont les mêmes
éléments qui composent cette montre mais
dans une montre carré ou dans une montre
mais on retrouve les élèves même les
éléments qui composent ces architectures
et puis si on veut créer une montre je
sais pas avec une autre typologie ou une
autre fonction la monteront d'un chrono
la main droite c'est juste une fonction
simple heure minute seconde date
mais j'ai tous mes éléments qui
permettent
de développer au fil du temps
des autres produits dans cette famille
vous allez me demander mais finalement
la méthode le créateur là-dedans mais
comment créer ces méthodes comment y
créer ses recettes finalement comment il
arrive dans un cas ou dans un autre
avoir quelque chose de différent à voir
une recette qui est jamais la même qui
est chaque fois appliquée dans dans un
projet bien bien défini ben c'est son
aspiration en fait et c'est là que ça
devient quelque chose de personnel et
pour moi il y a deux types d'aspirations
qui sont fondamentales dans mon travail
c'est mon laboratoire créatif et mes
travaux personnels
le laboratoire créatif
pour moi c'est exactement l'inverse de
ce que je fais pour mes clients un
client il va me briefer il va me
demander de lui décider de quelque chose
ou de créer une cohérence esthétique sur
un logo ou sur un produit
mais dans le cadre de mon laboratoire
j'inverse le processus en fait j'essaye
de tout remettre en question et de
repartir à zéro sans savoir dans quelle
direction je vais donc là cet exemple je
m'intéressais aux textures dans les
matières mais je ne savais pas du tout
la finalité de ces textures est-ce que
ça allait être une chaise est-ce que ça
allait être une lampe
je ne sais pas au départ ce qui
m'intéressait c'est de travailler des
textures et des matières sans avoir de
but défini ce qui est absolument
l'inverse
notre travail bien précis pour une
marque où on vous demande de dessiner un
logo vous demande de décider une montre
une chaise etc là il y a pas de but au
départ on inverse vraiment le processus
notre exemple de laboratoire d'idées
un travail que je viens de terminer avec
un collègue en Corée designer travail
qu'on a fait en collaboration dans une
galerie à Séoul
et le but là ça nous a intéressé de
travailler c'était de travailler sur la
munjar qui est on peut dire on peut dire
que c'est une pièce
iconique un élément pour la Corée un
objet très iconique pour la Corée on
s'est ramenique avec un savoir-faire en
particulier
fait de manière artisanale depuis
plusieurs centaines d'années par des
artisans formés etc et là notre but
était de revisiter cette forme et
d'amener des textures qui évidemment
n'était pas possible de réaliser à la
main et là le but de mon laboratoire
ça a été d'intégrer
une nouvelle technologie afin de mixer
le savoir-faire artisanal et une
nouvelle technologie afin d'amener
quelque chose d'intéressant en termes de
forme c'est cette texture que vous voyez
au milieu de l'objet
donc voilà le laboratoire vous voyez ça
me permet d'expérimenter des choses que
je ne fais pas au quotidien qui
permettent d'évoluer de chaque fois de
m'immerger dans un monde je parlais
d'immersion pour les pilotes là je me
suis immergé dans le savoir-faire d'un
artisan de ce que c'était une Mouja je
n'avais aucune idée au départ
de ce que c'était une Mouja
il commence à se faisait donc c'est ça
qui est intéressant pour un designer
pour un créatif en tout cas pour moi
c'est fondamental de chaque fois de
m'immerger de comprendre des mots
différents de me plonger dans une
univers que ce soit une marque que ce
soit un process finalement la curiosité
c'est toujours la même chose ça
fonctionne toujours la même chose
ensuite pour terminer ça ce sont des
travaux un peu plus personnels des
dessins par exemple à des dessins que et
là dans cette typologie de dessin ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de créer des formes
qui sont
inexistants dans la nature ou on trouve
dans un aucune typologie d'objets ou
même je fausses les perspectives
des choses qui sont irréalisables afin
de me créer un catalogue de nouvelles
formes
de manière abstraite et peut-être un
jour qu'elles vont peut-être me servir
dans un travail personnel dans un
travail très concret le but étant de me
délier de tout ce que j'ai appris de
désapprendre
tout ce que j'ai appris afin de
remodeler quelque chose de nouveau
peut-être dans un futur proche ou
lointain
voilà si on arrive au à la hauteur de
cette conférence à la conclusion
et pour moi la conclusion c'est qu'on ne
crée pas des icônes on les construit
voilà je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
et bonne soirée à vous
[Musique]